-Well, these are difficult times
to do an entertainment show.
These are difficult times
to do any show.
But these are also times when
we need each other the most.
In times like these, I think to
myself, "How is this happening?
How can this be happening?"
But I'm also thinking,
"How can I help?"
And being here tonight
and talking to you at home
and reassuring you that
we are going to be okay
and that this is not what
our country is about
is how I can help.
This is what happens when
there is no peaceful transition
of power and what happens
when there is bad leadership.
This is not how you lose.
If my grandfather were alive
today and saw what
was happening in the country
that he fought for,
he'd be disgusted.
People walking around with
the flag upside down,
thinking they're patriotic.
Today was not patriotism.
Today was terrorism.
I thought that
President-elect Biden --
President Biden said
it best when he said,
"We have to step up.
We're at our
best when we step up."
We've seen it over and over
again during this pandemic,
from the front-line workers to
the cashiers at grocery stores
to everyone delivering food
or raising money
for people who need it.
We are best when we
work together and step up.
But President Biden also said
something after his speech
that hit me even harder.
He said,
"Enough is enough is enough."
And I believe that is what
a majority of this country
has been saying, has been
screaming for a long time now.
Enough is enough.
Today was a disgrace.
Today was disappointing.
But, sadly,
today was not a surprise.
But it's important to remember
that this is not who we are.
I assure you there are more
good people than there are bad
and good will prevail.
Thank you for watching.